as I said being at the bank you're in an
outpost where you see the planet more
clearly I think than in many other jobs
almost because of the design of the
institution and the nature what it does
and having been around many years at a
high level i had i think more of a broad
view than most people have and when i
was the european vice president with
wolfensohn we went all over the prime
ministers in the ministers and the g8's
and the european summits and so forth
and at some point I had this feeling
which I then wrote about that in a way
there was no pilot in the cockpit on
many global issues that they wear these
UN summits and these g8 declarations and
so forth but that in true fact many of
the big global problems like global
warming being one we're not being
actively solved by the international
system as we know it and so one day I I
did something I did every year which was
to take a week off to write a major
speech i sat down and wrote a speech
about this question of why there were
some two dozen issues that were not
being solved deeply enough and fast
enough and why that was and what we
could do to accelerate this global
problem solving that seems to be so slow
to come by and that speech worked out
fine and then there was an extraordinary
moment where Chancellor Schroeder who
was then chancellor of germany asked the
World Bank for a briefing which is
remarkable actually yes to be briefed on
poverty and development issues and so we
had a meeting with him in a restaurant
yarn over on a sunday i remember
Wolfensohn Nick Stern who then wrote
this famous a climate change report for
the British government later and myself
and
Chancellor Schroder and two people and
since I had organized the meeting I had
kept one hour at the back of the meeting
for my ideas on global governance and
global issues and so Wolfensohn spoke
for a three or four hours and poverty
and development and then I started to
talk about global issues and Chancellor
shadow is very interested and Jim
Wolfensohn was intrigued and interested
as well and in the evening when we had
dinner together after a successful day
with Chancellor shorter i asked
Wolfensohn what to do about it and he
said these ideas go far beyond the World
Bank so write them up on under your own
name and that led me to write a book
which is a book that was critical of the
g7 of the UN and so forth but somehow I
got away with it while being in the
institution as a sitting vice president
and that shows you one more time how
open-minded the institution it was at
the time and and I'm grateful for that
and and then the book led into many
speeches and into a whole campaign on
these questions but that was the origin
of it
you